hello everybody mark var here and we
just hit 250,000 subscribers I say we
just hit it but we actually hit it last
night and now we have about 2,000 more
than that
so it's been absolutely incredible
because we gained about well exactly
fifty thousand subscribers in less than
two weeks that means that we're actually
ahead of pace to get to the million
subscribers by March 6 of next year
March 6 I can't even remember what day
it was exactly but we are doing an
incredible job
I mean you are doing an incredible job
and I can't I can't convey my gratitude
enough for how much what you guys are
doing means to me and um what we're
doing so I want you guys to know that
we're going to be doing another charity
livestream this Saturday this Saturday
coming up so on the what day is that I'm
totally unprepared the 13th that'll be
on the 13th of April on a Saturday we're
gonna start from 10:00 a.m. and go until
we hit our goal of fifteen thousand
dollars we're gonna be trying to raise
$15,000 um I still haven't nailed down
the specific charity but I'm pretty sure
we're gonna be raising money for
Alzheimer disease which is if you have
any family member that has gone through
that it's really really scary and
horrifying disease and it's actually
there's been a lot of breakthroughs
recently but the disease hasn't been
cured yet so this is like the best time
to contribute money towards this
specific research if we can actually
cure this if we're as close as I think
we are based on some articles I've read
then we got a sprint to the finish and
really help push it over the edge so I
would love for you guys to help us out
in this really really scary disease
because I mean it affects a lot of
people and it affects them in the worst
ways to not be able to remember your
family is just a nightmare for a lot of
people and I know me I would I would
definitely hate that so let's hope that
we can actually cure this one in the
next few years because there's been a
lot of really good research about it and
it just needs a little bit more so hope
you guys will join me I'm gonna try to
find a good Alzheimer research charity
that we can donate to it'll be on the
twitch channel and hopefully
we'll have Wade and Bob with me in the
room like we did in last year with a few
of the live streams just haven't been
able to coordinate it but hopefully the
schedules are lightening up so that we
can so please join me there'll be more
information later on the week for that
but other than that thank you guys so
much you have done an absolutely
incredible job for everything that I've
dreamed of so far like I I have I had
this dream and goal and to see it
happening before my eyes is just
absolutely incredible so like every
single month were able to raise our goal
in this is probably the biggest jump in
the goal that I've had for a long time
because we raised ten thousand dollars
last month and to raise another five
thousand on top of that it's pretty
incredible but I know that we go we can
do it and we only did it in like six
hours last time so I'm hoping that we'll
actually hit the full 12 hours this time
so please join me and once again just
thank you guys for the incredible things
that you've done to help this channel
grow it's been growing so incredibly
fast and you guys have been building
this community I've got a lot of big
stuff in planning right now because
suddenly I'm getting all these like
people that want to work with me and all
sorts of stuff like that and I'm really
happy to do it hopefully I'll be able to
tell you guys more about it as it comes
but for now just from the bottom of my
heart really thank you guys so much you
you all mean so much to me and it's it's
just incredible to think that there's a
quarter of a million subscribers that
thought my channel was worthy enough to
subscribe so honestly and truly thank
you all it's been the greatest feeling
in the world and I can't wait to see
what we can do in a month after month
and the difference that we can make so
thank you all so much for watching um
each and every day those those of you
who do like stop by my channel and leave
comments and do all that sorts of stuff
I try to keep up as much as I can
but I just can't anymore in that that's
one of the saddest things about this I
literally can't keep up I used to be
able to read every single comment on
every single video and I can't because
there are literally thousands of
comments on each video it's it's sad I
really wish I could connect better but I
think with the mail you know me reading
your personal stuff it's another way
that I can connect and still be able to
keep up I just can't respond to everyone
if you send me something more often than
not I have read it I've read every
single nail that I've been written in
most of the emails I have actually read
so if you don't get a response I'm
really sorry I wish I could but I would
kill myself if I kind of do that so just
to understand that I do care and I'm
never gonna stop caring about you know
each individual subscriber because I
said a long time ago that one subscriber
is still one subscriber no matter how
many you have in the pocket so it still
means so much even though we're getting
like 30,000 subscribers a day it still
means so much to know that you guys do
like one is still important
because one person can make a huge
difference no matter what the situation
is one person can always make a
difference so thank you again for those
of you who have been believing me
because I I I had doubts at first and
now I can finally see that things are
coming to fruition you could say so
seriously thank you guys I've rambled on
enough trying to thank you guys so you
guys in a Eagles are properly inflated
so I didn't do anything silly with my
moustache I'd like to keep these V logs
as serious as possible just so that I
can let you guys know that I'm serious
about how much this means to me so thank
you all so much for watching click write
in the comments below for good Alzheimer
charities because I would really like to
get one that's highly rated I've done
some research online but at the same
time your guys suggested mean a lot to
me so write in the comments below write
in the comments below for whatever you
want to say to me I'll try to read all
of them on this one specifically so
thank you guys again for everything
250,000 subscribers 1/4 of no thank you
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye